- [Instructor] The exchange
students were able to view,
but not handle,
the fragile artifacts at
the archeological site.
So they've underline fragile.
Maybe you think, do we
not want to change it?
Is fragile the right word to use,
or do we want to replace it
with weak, decrepit, or sickly?
So let's think about it.
Fragile means something that
you can break very easily,
so that actually seems to make sense.
You know, they're not, the
students aren't able to handle
the artifacts because
they're very easy to break.
So I could imagine that.
The exchange students were
able to view, but not handle,
the fragile artifacts at
the archeological site.
So I actually like fragile there,
but let's see how the other words fit in.
Weak.
So weak, if you're talking
about a thing being weak,
it means that, okay,
if you were to kind of,
it wouldn't be able to
support a lot of weight maybe,
or it does mean that it might kind of fail
under pressure somehow.
So it is close to fragile.
So, the exchange students were
able to view, but not handle,
the weak artifacts at
the archeological site.
Yeah, weak just doesn't as
strongly give this notion of
being easy to break.
Fragile really talks about
that, and it's very clear,
okay, you wouldn't want to touch.
You would kind of restrict
people touching something
that is fragile.
So I don't know.
This one is, I don't
feel so great about it.
Decrepit.
So decrepit is somethings
that's kind of old or worn out,
and artifacts are old and worn out,
but you're usually referring to,
like it could be people or a thing,
but I kind of think of
something very old and decrepit.
And decrepit by itself isn't
saying why you're not allowed
to touch it, I guess is the main takeaway.
The exchange students were
able to view, but not handle,
the decrepit artifacts at
the archeological site.
It's, you know, just because
something is old and worn out
doesn't mean that that's
the reason not to touch it.
The reason not to touch it
is because you could break it easily.
So I'll rule this one out.
Then you have sickly.
The exchange students were
able to view, but not handle,
the sickly artifacts at
the archeological site.
Well, sickly means, if you're
talking about a person,
which we're not in there,
it would mean someone who is sick often
or very easy to get sick,
or it could mean just
kind of a pungent smell,
or something that makes you ill,
and I don't think that's the reason why
they're not handling it.
If they said the students
were able to view,
but not smell, maybe you'd
go with the sickly artifacts,
and even that would
sound a little strange.
So the fact, I really like fragile here,
and all of these other ones
don't really feel as good.
So I'm gonna go with NO CHANGE...